[Music]
until that you guys have a ping-pong
table that's there and people in the
cast crew play here at all cuz we
compete against other shows just saying
okay again I've made it clear everyone
here on my show
if anyone enjoys themselves with ping
pong they're fired
I'm like Stalin yeah are you enjoying
yourself great work environment
no we owe a lot of ping pong and we have
massive competitions how are you a
competitive person yes I don't like to
lose right
I don't like I will do anything to win I
there was a some people would say that I
did a little cheating I would say I
didn't how do you cheat in ping pong I
would at the time this is a few years
ago I would go put on the tiniest outfit
known to mankind come down and I would
just play I don't see why that's
cheating right and then you know I do
things like oh I've gotta go grab this
ball make a no we we have the ball and I
go oh I gotta clean the floor you know I
was always kind of I won every time yeah
I don't know why and all these guys
wanted to play was weird they didn't
even care if they lost show drivers it
was weird
they didn't even have a pass they
shouldn't they should have tried to find
a gay ringer yeah Wow well I actually we
I looked around I found someone from the
show provided us with a photograph of
you in your ping-pong outfit yeah let's
take a look
[Laughter]
I so did not wear that it was sort of
like that really like that we're gonna
make where did I get that it's called
the Internet
my wife is saying what are you doing
it's for the show
that's something for the show Kayla's
coming guys get out of my little room
[Laughter]
that ruff a friend the face I make when
I'm high
[Music]
swore I did now well I don't know where
you're from are you are you a good
driver you're terrible drivers
you're like a very bad guy yeah I'm not
a great driver I think I told you last
time ever I almost hit your car when we
were driving through security
yes yeah that's what I was thinking I
was thinking a Hummer it was like my
reptile brain I'm thinking I remember
you almost killing yeah we're not the
best driver I admit it I'm open Leo I'm
open to it I know that I'm not great
people telling him tell me I'm not great
I almost hit you driving in one day it's
just you know it's just part of me right
you don't but using you stay two cars
though you don't you don't like like
ride bicycles or motorcycle no but I
totally want to get a motorcycle license
no see if you're bad at driving no don't
get a motorcycle license no no one's
promoting this idea right but I just may
be so cool I see the people on the
motorcycles and their signals they're
always like what does it mean oh they're
on meth yeah those aren't signal yeah I
can explain what's going on out there
yeah I'm pretty Street
I want to congratulate you you know
you've made it in this business when you
have your own bobblehead your own
bobblehead just came out you haven't
seen this yet oh my god
there you are this is you on that know
what uh that's got to be exciting for
you yeah I mean obviously it looks
exactly like me I mean the only thing we
have in common is the constant movement
of my head it's great it's really you I
guess I've made it you have I mean
that's pretty I was excited when I got
my bobblehead it's not it's pretty much
it's from it's similar to yours not to
take any air out of your tires but we
bring out my bobblehead please
[Music]
[Applause]
clears right there
is yours and then there's mine
now really congratulations though you've
got to be thrilled I'm gonna get you one
yeah